as all the major TV networks announce
their pickups and cancellations for the
upcoming season the biggest surprise
came from ABC even though the Tim Allen
show Last Man Standing was the network's
second highest rated comedy ABC decided
to drop the sitcom after six seasons why
would they end one of their most
successful shows without warning here
are some of the reasons
last-man-standing took a fall a major
Network shift The Last Man Standing
aired on ABC the network didn't actually
own the show the sitcom was produced by
20th Century Fox which met ABC had to
pay licensing fees every season this may
have factored into the cancellation
because it made the show more expensive
than some of their other comedies still
that may not be the whole story
ABC's fresh off the boat is also
produced by 20th Century Fox but was
renewed for a fourth season despite
lower ratings ABC Entertainment
president Channing Dungy said that axing
Last Man Standing was simply a business
decision the network decided to make
Friday a night for dramas and once the
scheduling switch was made they felt
last-man-standing had no place to go the
show shared the night with dr. ken which
was also cancelled though the Ken Jeong
program netted half as many viewers on
an average night Dungy explained the
difference saying last-man-standing was
a challenging one for me because it was
a steady performer in the ratings but
once we made the decision not to
continue with comedies on Fridays that
was where we landed Fridays will be all
drama on ABC now including Once Upon a
Time and Marvel's upcoming Inhumans
series budgeting woes for a lot of shows
season 7 is a year of contract
negotiations
Last Man Standing was no exception Tim
Allen's contract needed to be renewed
which more than likely meant a pretty
big raise since the show made less money
for ABC because it was owned by Fox and
because Allen already had a pretty
sizable salary the network may not have
wanted to pump even more money into the
sitcom sure ratings were good and good
ratings typically equal lots of Network
dollars but last-man-standing also
didn't have the ideal audience
advertisers want viewers in the 18 to 49
age group while the program did fairly
well in that demographic the show's
audience skewed older if advertisers
weren't willing to shell
the big bucks ABC wasn't willing to foot
the growing bill playing politics after
Last Man Standing cancellation was
announced rumor quickly spread that ABC
pulled the plug because of Alan's openly
conservative politics the show's premise
rested on an old-school guy who rails
against PC culture and wishes we could
go back to the good old days we want to
have sports sporting events with men I
don't get it because if you beat a woman
you're a bully if you lose to a woman
your embarrassment some suspect the
network may have wanted to distance
themselves from that conservative
viewpoint especially since Dungey has
previously said Donald Trump's
presidency has made her rethink the
network's programming slate I think any
woman would know the value of being
compared to such a device like this in
real life Alan is a proud Republican and
has stirred up some controversy with his
off-kilter comments about his status as
a rare conservative in Hollywood
everybody believes thirties Germany
Wisconsin's Republican Governor Scott
Walker tweeted his support to Alan
stating looks like ABC is playing
politics with your show despite decent
ratings sad conservative pundit Glenn
Beck chimed in during his online radio
show vowing to start looking into why
the show got cancelled in response to
the rumors the network has insisted
politics played no part in
last-man-standing demise as ABC
president Dungy put it I canceled Last
Man Standing for the same business and
scheduling reasons I cancelled the real
O'Neal's dr. ken the catch and American
crime straightforward as that might
sound it did nothing to stem the tide of
fan outrage when life knocks you down
you don't lie in the canvas cryin no
reading like Al Gore after the 2000
election
he blew up like the Hindenburg fighting
back
days after the cancellation was
announced Tim Allen tweeted that he was
stunned and blindsided by the network I
called home for six years and his fans
were just as Earth a change.org petition
to save the show drew more than a
quarter of a million signatures of
support during the days after the show's
fate was sealed though the vocal support
proves the show has a fervent fan base
its chances for finding a new home are
low according to Deadline Fox considered
taking the show but decided they didn't
have a place on their schedule the
possibility of the show moving to
streaming services or other outlets is
also reportedly remote all of the above
in the end it looks like a number of
different factors played into
last-man-standing surprising
cancellation ABC is rearranging their
schedule and the show was deceptively
expensive and to think that politics had
absolutely nothing to do with it might
be a bit of a stretch despite the
official line whether a boycott of the
network or a fan petition will
ultimately have much impact remains to
be seen protestors are rarely interested
in facts and unfortunately we don't get
picketed by angry historian for now at
least it looks like the last man
standing probably won't get back up
anytime soon thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]